hey guys it is the 20th of august today
my name is Jess and I've got a monies
for you he sits up in Madame
fan-favorite JRPG final fantasy 7 has
arrived on iOS today with some brand new
features based on the PC version of the
game this $16 offering includes two new
features first off you can disable
random enemy encounters that you'd
normally have to deal with on world and
area maps which means you can opt to
only take on battles relevant to the
story anybody who's played an RPG before
it's probably wondering how you're going
to have the experience to take on those
main battles if you skip everything else
and that's where the other new feature
comes in you can now max out all your
stats with the touch of a button if
you're feeling like that sort of defeats
the purpose then I'm right there with
you long-suffering destiny fans can
rejoice today as Bungie have revealed
their VIP rewards for the taken King VIP
rewards can be picked up by players
who've reached level 30 or own both
expansion packs by the 31st of august
von z released a trailer showing off all
the cool [ __ ] that those who have
already become legend and sung hundreds
of hours into destiny can expect to get
among the rewards are a new Ghost skin
and you emblem a sweet new sparrow and
call new shadowy outfits so everybody
knows you're better than them finally
Bethesda have addressed fan complaints
from those who weren't all that
impressed with the graphics and gameplay
of fallout 4 marketing chief Pete Hines
told the UK tabloid Metro that everybody
is entitled to their opinion on the
gameplay and
fix addressing concerns that flat floors
gameplay looks too similar to its
predecessor fallout 3 times said you
ought to be able to see things that are
recognizable or similar or whatever
because we didn't make a completely
different game but at the same time when
you're playing it its a mix of familiar
and different if you jump into the game
and you play it for an extended period
of time you'll start to feel the
differences and how much some things
have changed let me know down in that
comment box if you like the look of
Fallout 4 so far or not and why you can
add the games but we've got new XCOM 2
gameplay and a news on what coming next
for driveclub that is all the stuff that
I wanted to tell you about today but do
you remember that tomorrow I'll have my
top five stories of the whole gaming
week all ready to go for you for season